foreign
[Music]
the blue skin aliens that have captured
the imagination of people around the
world but are they really from that
planet Moon or are they from elsewhere
or created by some other alien species
so here in this video we will discuss
quite a few reasons why these Navi
aliens might not be as they seem to be
an endemic species of Pandora so let's
get to it let's take a look first at
their biology the navi have a humanoid
Anatomy with feline traits including
flat noses white eyes pointed ears that
can move independently a prehensile tail
and their bones are made of a naturally
occurring carbon fiber and they have
just four digits on each hand and foot
with opposable thumbs on each their skin
is blue due to the presence of cyan and
pigments which changes when exposed to
UV light they are bioluminescent
freckles dotted around the skin and
appear to follow the circularity or the
neurological systems they have red blood
cells which indicate hemoglobin content
but their cells do not have DNA rather
they have a strange nucleic acid strain
that allows them to store and process
genetic information as with many of the
pandoran wildlife they have a neural cue
which are like large neuron fibers to
share biological information so with
these things in mind let's see the
differences between them and the animal
life of the planet Moon of Pandora will
the navi have four limbs as bipedal
tetrapods While most Mandarin animals
have a total of six limbs as hexapods
with the exception of the mountain
banshees this is the main difference as
we can see most animals with a shared
lineage in a family tree share the same
number of Limbs whether it's birds
reptiles amphibians or mammals as seen
on Earth the navi also have two eyes as
opposed to the normal four eyes and many
other species in that world they also
lack the upperculi which are respiratory
holes in the body while the other life
forms of that planet all possess them
and lastly they have only one neural cue
While most megaphone of that planet Moon
has two
so with these differences in mind the
question now is why are they so
different and are they originally not
from that world is it likely that the
navi diverged a long time ago from the
common pandoran phylogenetic or
evolutionary tree or were they from
another planet or even more radical were
they genetically engineered at some
point in the past by another alien
species which isn't quite a far of
assumption as we can see the avatars
being a human creation so similar to
these blue skin creatures the first
Theory being that they are actually
aliens from another world it's quite
enticing to ponderable but if they
really are then where have all their
space technology disappeared off to and
why do they have so much in common with
the biodiversity there even though
having quite a few differences as well
so this theory is slightly just a theory
the next one is that they are an
artificially engineered species created
by another alien race probably thousands
or millions of years in the past for
some unknown reason Studies by
xenobiologists there in that franchise
that Universe suggests that the navi
have experienced just a few evolutionary
changes for millions of years quite a
contrasting bit of information as they
also state that they rapidly evolved to
adapt to their surroundings for example
the omatikaya a slender built and are
better evolved for arboreal and Forest
life while the Met kaina have many
evolved features like a battle tail
finn-like lower arms and feet bigger
eyes with nictating membranes which make
them perfect for marine life there are
also other Navi races with their own
specific traits were they all engineered
to be perfect for their respective
environments by these Ancient Aliens
yeah I sound like a conspiracy theorist
but is it really crazy to theorize that
they may have been created by another
alien species way back in the past
probably millions of years back to house
the dying alien populations
Consciousness in a body engineered to
live as a natural species in that planet
Moon of Pandora just as the Avatar of
Jake took on his memories and
Consciousness from the dying human body
doesn't seem so crazy now does it what
if James Cameron in the fourth or fifth
installment of the franchise decide to
reveal this truth it would explain why
they are bipedal quarter pets instead of
hexapedal animals why they have only two
eyes instead of four why they lack of
peculi and they have only one neural cue
if humans could create avatars that can
reproduce and Advance alien species in
the past could have done the same
there are other pieces of information
which are very interesting as said
earlier the navi have a naturally
occurring carbon fiber in their bones to
produce a carbon fiber the carbon atoms
are bonded together in crystals that are
aligned parallel to each other this
requires a high temperature and a great
amount of pressure this isn't to say
that life forms cannot produce carbon
fiber naturally it's only something that
is peculiar as carbon fiber is hard to
find in nature and is artificially
generated
so to find it in a species that is at
the top of the food chain in a planet's
ecology which possesses many anatomical
features that diverge from the normal
animal life or from The evolutionary
tree over there it's quite a puzzle to
say the least
we also have other questions which we
will answer in the next video questions
like what are those gigantic Stone
arches why do the Pandora animals attack
non-endemic life forms like humans isn't
that a form of sentience if directed by
AWA then is the goddess of Pandora a
gigantic biological Quantum
supercomputer and if so it's the entire
planet alive like Unicron from the
Transformers franchise so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this one do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam